bonjour je suis Marielle m de la chambre
de métier et de l'artisanat merci de
participer à la cinquième édition de la
journée découverte des métiers
d'artisanat organisés par la Chambre de
métiers et l'artisanat en partenariat
avec la Faculté des Métiers des sols le
CFA du bâtiment et celui des Apprentis
d'Auteuil les cinq couettes de
conférences que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la Semaine
nationale de l'apprentissage sont
consacrés à l'orientation des jeunes
vers les métiers de l'automobile du bout
de la fleuristerie de la beauté et du
bâtiment métier qui font partie de la
grande famille de
avant de commencer notre web conférence
j'aimerais vous faire part de quelques
éléments de contexte
aujourd'hui l'artisanat français est un
secteur qui a le vent en poupe un
million 830 000 entreprises artisanales
ont été recensés en juin 2022
aujourd'hui un créateur d'entreprise sur
4 est un artisan ce qui atteste du
dynamisme du secteur
quête de sens valorisation du fabriqué
en France recherche d'épanouissement
professionnel et personnel toutes ces
valeurs poussent aussi bien les jeunes
que les personnes en reconversion
[Musique]
vers l'artisanat véritablement porteur
d'un nouveau hôtel économique la preuve
000 apprentis ont été formés dans
l'artisanat
sachez que la formation par la voix de
l'apprentissage offre de belles
opportunités d'avenir puisque 80% des
apprentis sont en emploi dans les 6 mois
qui suivent leur formation
l'apprentissage vous permet également de
devenir entrepreneur en effet près de la
moitié des dirigeants actuels
d'entreprises artisanales ont été
eux-mêmes apprentis voilà de quoi
alimenter vos discussions et surtout
nous espérons que cet événement
suscitera des vocations
place maintenant à la présentation de la
filière des métiers du goût
autour de la table nous accueillons
Bilel Hanoun
apprenti bac pro cuisine
Stéphanie Dubillon chargée de
développement au CFA de la Faculté des
Métiers et Olivier goutte formateur en
cuisine
alors bonjour à tous donc moi je suis la
charge développement de la faculté des
métiers pour la filière métier du goût
donc nous dans notre filière nous avons
plusieurs formations nous faisons du CFA
nous faisons des formations en cuisine
service en salle pâtisserie boulangerie
capsr également titre pro donc nous
proposons en soins de la Faculté des
Métiers 90 formations et nous avons
aussi un une grosse semaine de
partenaires d'entreprises avec
lesquelles nous travaillons
régulièrement comme disait tout à
l'heure comme était dit tout à l'heure
la présentation généralement
l'apprentissage est un tremplin pour
l'emploi et environ 80% des jeunes
trouvent un emploi à l'issue de leur
formation
[Musique]
de votre parcours après voilà tout est
différent par rapport à ça donc merci
beaucoup
donc là pour définir ce qu'est
l'apprentissage donc l'apprentissage est
un CDD c'est à dire un contrat durée
déterminé avec un début de contrat une
fin de contrat qui doit couvrir toute la
durée de la formation si votre formation
doit durer un an le contrat doit durer
un an en formation deux ans le contrat 2
ans et ainsi de suite donc qu'est-ce que
le contrat d'apprentissage le public
visé généralement enfin c'est pas
généralement
l'apprentissage lui sans rien pour des
jeunes de 15 à 29 ans ça peut être plus
ou moins enfin moins de 15 ans et plus
de 29 ans en fonction de certaines
dérogations et certains statuts on va
pas rentrer dans le détail
qu'est-ce que l'alternance exactement
c'est ce que je sais tout à l'heure donc
c'est une
[Musique]
une alternance c'est une formation donc
vous participez aussi bien vos cours en
formation qu'en entreprise
donc quand vous signez un contrat
d'apprentissage vous êtes salarié avec
les mêmes droits et obligations que tout
salarié en entreprise et quand vous êtes
en formation donc il faut suivre
également le règlement de l'école à
laquelle vous appartenez et donc vous
êtes comme je disais tout à l'heure vous
êtes et en école et en entreprise donc
ça permet d'acquérir une expérience
beaucoup plus large comme je disais tout
à l'heure donc la durée du contrat va
dépendre de la formation donc nous on a
des formations d'un an deux ans trois
ans et la rémunération c'est ce que je
disais à une grille de salaire donc par
exemple si vous êtes mineur la première
année nous allons voir ça sur le siège
suivant parce que c'est
quand c'est ce que je disais lorsque
vous êtes mineur que vous n'avez jamais
fait de contrat d'apprentissage votre
premier salaire est de 27%, c'est bien
un peu plus de 400 euros si jamais entre
temps vous passez majeur vous pouvez
avoir vous avez 43 % ainsi de suite et
la durée du sphin le salaire correspond
vraiment en fonction de votre âge de
votre niveau de formation là on peut pas
entrer dans le détail là c'est vraiment
une grille basique et finalement le
salaire au cas par cas donc non
seulement il faut être aussi en contrat
d'apprentissage donc pour les gens de 15
à 29 ans voici il faut être en contrat
de professionnalisation quand par
exemple vous voulez vous réorienter
professionnellement c'est le cas
effectivement chez nous on a quelques
personnes qui ont une quarantaine
d'années qui sont en compte à pro et qui
sont en alternance comme les apprentis
voilà c'est différent mais voyez qu'on
est un peu plus rémunéré parce que c'est
vrai que l'âge
participe là je peux augmenter quand
même le salaire donc voilà la crise de
rémunération et en fonction de certaines
de certains centres enfin de certains
activités par exemple dans la Coiff
mesure le SMIC enfin le SMIC horaire
peut être un peu plus supérieur à tout
ce qui est le salaire de base voilà pour
le salaire
merci
vous êtes salarié vous ne l'êtes pas
et bien vous avez raison vous avez tous
répondu vrai et en signant votre contrat
d'apprentissage vous devenez
effectivement salarié de l'entreprise
bienvenue dans le plus grand centre de
formation d'alternance du sud-francilien
la Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne
c'est 90 formations gratuites et
rémunérées du CAP au Bac + 5 dans 8
filières métiers réparties sur trois
sites
la Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne
accompagne chaque année 3000 apprentis
et 5000 stagiaires de la formation
continue vers des parcours
professionnels réussis et de réels
opportunités d'emplois en effet avec un
réseau de 2000 entreprises partenaires
elle affiche un taux d'insertion
professionnelle de plus de 80%
[Musique]
sur le site des fricours Courcouronnes
la filière métier du goût propose des
formations en boulangerie pâtisserie
cuisine et services en restaurant
d'anciens apprentis aujourd'hui salariés
ou chef d'entreprise et des apprentis
actuellement en formation témoignent de
leur expérience
les professeurs avec qui on peut très
vite bien s'entendre après au niveau des
locaux l'espace est très pratique à
utiliser ici à la Faculté des Métiers on
est très suivi par nos profs ils nous
encadrent énormément ils nous booste ils
sont là dans les mauvais moments mais
aussi dans les bons voilà on s'amuse
beaucoup mais on travaille aussi en même
temps et le fait d'avoir aussi des
petites classes ça permet au prof d'être
plus proche des élèves la Faculté des
Métiers on nous transmet la passion et
c'est ce qui fait que généralement on
s'en sort très bien aux examens
l'apprentissage m'a apporté une maturité
déjà et ça m'a permis de prendre
confiance en moi et de montrer que je
suis capable j'ai devenu une médaille
d'argent au concours meilleure apprenti
de France j'ai gagné le concours de la
meilleure baguette de tradition 2019 je
pense que pour un patron qui prend un
jeune qui sort d'apprentissage il va
plus donner sa confiance et on va être
beaucoup plus opérationnel le travail
j'ai trouvé du travail assez facilement
avec une formation prêt apprentie cap en
deux ans BP en 2 ans une formation
internationale ça m'a ouvert des portes
sur Paris beaucoup de portes du coup
j'ai plus facilement rentrer dans les
restaurants qui sont difficiles d'accès
si on n'a pas de diplôme moi
personnellement je garde de très bons
souvenirs et j'espère garder encore
longtemps contact avec nos formateurs
qui nous ont suivis
de formation tout s'est très bien passé
je regrette pas du tout d'être venu dans
CFA et le système à faire je le ferai
si tu es à deux pas de la gare RER et
organisée autour d'espace vert arboré le
campus d'Évry de la faculté de l'Essonne
propose des équipements dédiés modernes
et performants deux amphithéâtres
un restaurant d'applications
un centre de ressources
et un complexe sportif
deux espaces de restauration sont à
votre disposition self et cafétéria
enfin la Faculté des Métiers de
l'Essonne dispose d'un service d'accès à
l'alternance proposant notamment une
prépa apprentissage et permettant à la
faculté des métiers des soins d'être
fiers d'intégrer tout type de handicap
alors n'hésitez pas rejoignez-nous
alors comme vous avez pu voir alors on
n'est pas plutôt voir donc la vidéo
présentée des apprentis des anciens
apprentis et des responsables
d'entreprise
qui présentaient les métiers mais la
Faculté des Métiers ce n'est pas que les
métiers du goût nous avons trois sites
alors abondo nous avons tout ce qui est
industrie à Évry donc c'est tout ce qui
est artisanat on a également du
tertiaire donc hôtellerie tourisme
commerce ventes distribution
énergétique donc c'est là il y a quand
même plus de choses à Évry et à Massy
c'est tout ce qui est tertiaire donc
comptabilité ressources humaines gestion
commerce donc là nous avons à peu près
tous les ans 3000 apprentis pour 90
formations dédiées allons allant du CAP
enfin même du titre pro jusqu'au Bac+5
donc l'apprentissage c'est vraiment un
tremplin déjà parce que vous travaillez
en même temps et puis vous pouvez très
bien commencer par une formation
inférieure aux bac pour finir avec un
bac + 5 donc ça c'est en fonction de vos
parcours de vos envies mais ce n'est
vraiment pas fermé vous avez vraiment un
choix de de métier et de parcours
donc c'est très intéressant pour ceux
qui veulent s'orienter vers l'emploi
donc là c'est Monsieur couté qui va vous
présenter les différents métiers
bonjour à tout le monde donc les
différents métiers on a déjà comme ma
collaboratrice l'a dit on a pâtisserie
la boulangerie la cuisine qui sont dans
les métiers du goût où là on part d'une
formation d'un titre qualifiant au après
au-dessus on peut faire un PSR à Jean
polyvalent restauration qui est plus
dédié le titre pro et le PSR vers la
collectivité donc là avec un menu adapté
avec des menus beaucoup plus simple avec
des matières aussi qui sont un peu plus
allégées après on monte sur des diplômes
comme cap et
la CAP ont un an et cap sur deux ans où
là on apprend vraiment un métier de la
cuisine traditionnelle après par la
suite on peut aussi monter sur un bac
pro en 3 ans et
un bac oui en trois ans et un brevet
professionnel en deux ans mais pour un
blu-ray professionnel il faut d'abord au
moins cap
avant par la suite si on veut encore
continuer on peut monter sur un BTS
Hôtellerie Restauration donc on a le
noeud à Évry nous avons les trois
options BTS option ABC restera service
culinaire et
manager réception et donc voilà on a un
beau panel après comme ma collègue l'a
dit c'est de l'alternance ou bah c'est
aussi à vous de trouver un patron
quelque chose qui va vous coller par
rapport à votre formation et nous à
l'école on va vous apprendre à
travailler sur la posture sur les gestes
sur réaliser une recette de A à Z savoir
selon le diplôme vous avez soit entré
plat dessert donc à apprendre dans un
temps à partir à vous organiser et à
réaliser cette recette ces recettes du
mois et donc voilà donc ça prend selon
les années d'études que vous avez on
vous apprend tranquillement à monter en
compétences et être capable de réaliser
ce qu'on vous demande en autonomie au
début vous allez travailler en groupe
par la suite on va petit groupe et
jusqu'à un individuel donc on essaye de
vraiment de de
vous amener d'essayer de
que vous ayez l'examen et sans vous on
peut rien faire donc c'est vraiment un
engagement c'est des métiers qui ne sont
pas faciles on a aussi la pâtisserie et
la boulangerie c'est des métiers où faut
pas se le cacher ou les horaires sont
pas faciles vous amusez pas quand vos
copains sont à l'école donc vous vous
travaillez pendant vos copains sont de
repos le soir le week-end les jours
fériés mais à côté de ça c'est des
métiers de passion c'est des métiers où
vous aurez jamais de problème pour
l'emploi
ou vous apprendrez de belles choses à
partir de produits bruts on arrive à les
sublimer et amener vraiment donner envie
aux gens et se faire plaisir donc
beaucoup de choses intéressantes aussi
même en pâtisserie c'est pareil à partir
de produits comme de la farine on arrive
à transformer des tartes des gâteaux des
pâtisseries vraiment sublimes en
boulangerie pareil on va vous apprendre
à partir de produits de base farine
levure crée sont pas différentes
textures différentes formes de couleurs
donc beaucoup de choses après je pense
aussi des autres métiers ou pas donc la
coiffure c'est pareil
que Michael laboratrice qui viendra par
la suite vous parlera donc de
l'esthétique et de la coiffure donc
voilà mes métiers très enrichissants
aujourd'hui il y a pas beaucoup de
métiers qui peuvent se narrer de de
pouvoir avoir une reconnaissance
mondiale par rapport à leur spécialité
nous là il a les métiers du goût on est
on est nos diplômes sont reconnus
mondialement et on est on est recruté on
peut travailler n'importe où sur la
planète par la suite une fois que vous
avez votre diplôme vous avez votre
expérience vos compétences c'est des
métiers qui sont très recherchés donc
aujourd'hui non seulement vous pouvez
avoir un diplôme intéressant déjà avec
des connaissances mais derrière vous
avez le monde que vous êtes ouvert la
seule chose c'est voilà faut être
performant il faut il faut être organisé
il faut être ambitieux il faut être
professionnel donc voilà je pense que je
sais pas
merci merci
alors on vous invite à nouveau à
répondre à quelques petites questions
donc combien d'apprentis pour un contrat
à durée indéterminée après leurs études
20% 80%, 50 % la plupart d'entre vous
ont choisi le 80% et bien vous avez
raison
pour la plupart d'entre vous en fait
puisque 80% des apprentis trouve à
l'issue de leur apprentissage soit une
poursuivre leur formation soit ils
peuvent être embauchés donc essayez une
embauche à 80%, donc belle performance
dans le monde entier comme
à savoir que que
contrairement à des gens qui ne
connaissent pas trop le métier qui vont
être embauchés
sans diplôme vous vous êtes forts de
compétences de de savoir et du coup les
professionnels sont sûrement très
friands de ce du personnel qui a un
diplôme qui a des vraies connaissances
ça fait en général on montre rapidement
en grade le salaire augmente aussi et
c'est vraiment quelque chose c'est pour
ça qu'on a quand même 80% d'embauche par
la suite c'est parce que Les
professionnels savent qu'avec une
personne qui a un diplôme même à rien
qu'un cap c'est du personnel qui a des
qualifications des connaissances
professionnelles et qui a une rigueur de
calorique quelqu'un qui n'est pas
forcément du métier qui a pas forcément
de diplôme bah peut se lasser peut pas
comprendre la logique du métier donc
voilà l'apprentissage quelque chose de
vraiment bénéfique pour vous
alors donc moi je me présente je suis
donc Cécile Gary médiatrice de
l'apprentissage donc en fait
j'interviens quand il y a des soucis en
entreprise oui ça arrive mais je vous
rassure la plupart du temps ça se passe
très très bien
voilà on va essayer de je vais essayer
de vous donner trois petits conseils
sous forme de tuto
voilà comme c'est la mode en ce moment
on essaie de s'adapter
et surtout que ça vous parle le plus
possible
trois petits points pour effectivement
bien enclencher
à mon sens
votre apprentissage
le premier point c'est montrer sa
motivation alors ça englobe beaucoup de
choses montrer sa motivation par exemple
c'est arriver à l'heure faire attention
à la politesse enfin voilà le Béaba on
va dire mais effectivement
c'est très important parce
qu'effectivement il faut être conscient
que du coup comme
tout le monde a pu vous le préciser
avant moi vous êtes dans un avant
salarié donc vous êtes payé donc chaque
minute compte chaque heure compte et
vous faites partie d'une équipe donc ça
change quand même la donne vous avez pu
à l'école voilà en entreprise c'est plus
c'est plus le même rapport voilà ça il
faut bien bien en être conscient montrer
sa motivation c'est aussi ne pas hésiter
à
à demander une nouvelle tâche si jamais
vous tournez un plan rond parce que bah
le mettre d'apprentissage a peut-être
d'autres choses à faire enfin je veux
dire dans le monde concret
[Musique]
on est complètement conscient que vous
êtes très jeune que c'est aussi vaincre
sa timidité c'est pas facile d'aller
chercher d'aller chercher une autre
tâche comment ça va être perçu comment
je vais le faire vraiment ne pas hésiter
on pourra jamais
on pourra jamais vous vous le reprocher
en tout cas
au sein de l'entreprise de voilà de
montrer un petit peu votre motivation et
votre envie de bien faire
le deuxième point c'est de se passer de
son téléphone portable alors pourquoi
j'insiste là dessus voilà je pense que
c'est un point qui revient régulièrement
c'est assez récurrent et moi
effectivement bien sûr
bien placé pour le savoir dans tout dans
tous les litiges que je peux que je peux
avoir effectivement c'est quelque chose
qui revient assez régulièrement
si c'est pas pour dire presque à chaque
fois donc c'est vraiment j'insiste là
dessus je vraiment on n'est pas là à
vous dire non pas de téléphone on sait
très bien que c'est juste pas possible
pour vous même pour nous ça reste
compliqué donc j'imagine pour vous il
faut que ce soit des choses quand même
qui soit réalisables vous avez des
pauses vous avez des temps de pause mais
c'est vraiment important que vous soyez
vraiment concentré à 100% sur le fait de
d'apprendre votre votre métier c'est pas
simple
ça nécessite beaucoup beaucoup de de
d'attention de votre part
même si je sais que c'est compliqué et
que c'est difficile et que ça représente
beaucoup de choses vraiment
j'insiste faites bien attention à ça et
il y a un temps pour tout vous aurez
vous aurez des temps de pause ou vous
pourrez où vous pourrez bien évidemment
retrouver votre téléphone portable en
plus si vous laissez entre 1h30 vous
allez voir vous allez avoir plein de
notifications plein de messages pour la
satisfaction la satisfaction personnelle
et bien vous
signal vous verrez donc l'étiquette les
snapchat
il faut éviter en fait pendant le temps
de travail ça serait comme sympa si je
peux pas mettre de couper au-delà de ça
c'est que le téléphone aussi ce qu'il
faut penser c'est que en cuisine dans
les métiers du goût c'est interdit c'est
parce que votre téléphone je pense que
vous le passez pas avec du produit
régulièrement plusieurs fois dans la
journée voilà votre téléphone vous
touchez avec les mains vous touchez
n'importe quoi c'est rempli de microbes
et de bactéries pour une hygiène c'est
interdit pour la protection au travail
avec des choses qui peuvent les salir
les n'est pas là donc pour une question
d'hygiène c'est interdit donc après un
moment on est au travail on est au
travail quand je sais pas peut-être par
exemple derrière la piscine vous
l'amenez pas dans l'eau votre téléphone
il y a des choses il y a des choses
logiques là c'est pareil quand on est en
entreprise nos téléphones on les
officiers pour une raison de sécurité on
est on peut pas être concentré sur
quelque chose et puis regarder son
téléphone donc et puis pour les raisons
d'hygiène on
interdit le téléphone en cuisine voilà
question de l'hygiène là c'est vraiment
propre voilà
mais effectivement j'essaie de vous
donner des conseils qui sont valables
vraiment dans tous les métiers mais
effectivement l'hygiène l'hygiène dans
le métier du
blond et un point fondamental
le troisième point c'est solliciter des
échanges avec le maître d'apprentissage
alors pourquoi aussi je m'explique
c'est ne pas hésiter effectivement à
instaurer moi si j'ai vraiment un
conseil à vous donner à instaurer dès le
départ en fait des points
de dialogue alors même si c'est 5
minutes on vous demande pas de faire un
quart d'heure 30 minutes les mettre
d'apprentissage souvent n'ont pas de
temps enfin je veux dire on est tout à
fait conscient là dessus mais c'est
quand même voilà les maîtres
d'apprentissage
l'entreprise a pris un apprenti
c'est une charge
on en est bien conscient l'apprenti pour
l'apprenti aussi donc effectivement bien
prendre ces cinq petites minutes moi ce
que j'essaye de dire la plupart du temps
est-ce qu'il fonctionne bien moi dans
mon expérience et dans mes expériences
c'est effectivement je sais pas quels
sont quel sera selon votre rythme mais
si vous avez par exemple une semaine
école une semaine entreprise je dis ça
peut être deux semaines deux semaines à
la fin de la semaine entreprise ce que
ce soit le jeudi ou le vendrit le
vendredi excusez-moi ouh c'est la
première donc
ou le vendredi effectivement c'est bien
de faire un point sur en gros alors
voilà qu'est-ce qui a péché qu'est-ce
que j'ai mal fait en gros qu'est-ce que
j'ai bien fait faire vraiment des points
sur les points négatifs les points
positifs voilà tu as là tu as été retard
deux fois alors fais attention là-dessus
là tu as fait voilà vraiment faire un
point et pas hésiter en fait même si
c'est pas super agréable à entendre
toujours Ben et puis vice versa
l'apprenti peut dire aussi des choses à
l'entreprise bah vous voyez moi j'ai là
par exemple j'ai demandé un conseil on
m'a pas répondu
vous voyez des choses des choses et
voilà et moi ça m'a un peu embêté
vraiment tout de suite en fait instaurer
tout de suite les problématiques ou les
choses qui vont bien tout de suite même
si c'est 5 minutes je le répète c'est
des choses qui fonctionnent bien et
c'est un store tout de suite le dialogue
au sein de l'entreprise parce que si
vous attendez trois mois quatre mois
pour l'instaurer c'est fini ça sera déjà
fait vos habitudes seront déjà fait donc
c'est voilà
faut penser que votre patron mettre
d'apprentissage au format il est un
petit peu comme votre formateur au CFA
ou votre prof différents profs à l'école
c'est qu'il est aussi là pour vous
accompagner pour vous apprendre de
chutes des choses
vous imaginons que même dans n'importe
quelle matière maths français des choses
que vous avez pas forcément bien compris
à l'école votre patron votre maître
d'apprentissage peut vous aider si selon
le métier que vous faites Coiff
d'ailleurs boulangerie n'importe quel
métier métier il est aussi là pour si
vous avez mal compris de la façon on
peut nous formateur on essaie de vous
amener on a quand même une vingtaine
d'élèves en classe à peu près en cuisine
en atelier un peu moins mais on peut pas
forcément passer tout notre tension un
élève on a plusieurs élèves on essaye
d'être le plus performant mais des fois
on élève on prend on comprend pas
forcément de la ce qui a été expliqué
pas correctement et le fait d'échanger
avec votre maître d'apprentissage ça
permet d'avoir une autre vision la plus
le temps il peut revenir s'il y a des
techniques que vous avez pas bien
acquéri et ben vous pouvez retravailler
avec lui en parler lui il va peut-être
pas vous le faire de suite mais il va
prendre un peu de temps par la suite
donc c'est un vrai échange des fois ça
ça évite des problèmes des conflits
aussi donc le fait d'avoir un échange
avec votre maître d'apprentissage
c'est important on l’implique dans votre
formation car il est déjà impliqué c'est
sûr que si vous arrivez en entreprise
vous dites rien ce que vous avez fait à
l'école bah lui il va pas voir vos
difficultés il va pas voir vos problèmes
et donc du coup pour lui c'est de la qui
donc vous ne mangez quelque chose vous
pouvez en conflit parce que lui il sera
pas vos problèmes vos difficultés donc
un vrai échange est important
un rapport de
de dialogue et d'ins
taurer très important donc voilà
exactement
alors donc là on vous expliquait tous
les métiers donc là si vous voulez
vraiment vous inscrire à la faculté des
métiers c'est plutôt simple il faut
aller sur le site donc vous voyez c'est
inscrit donc fac métier qui a trans.fr
n'oubliez surtout pas de 91 donc une
fois que vous êtes sur le site en haut
sur votre gauche sur votre droite vous
avez un petit onglet ou c'est indiqué ce
préinscrire en
ça c'est voyant donc cliquez dessus
alors vous allez vous réinscrire et par
la suite les assistantes vont regarder
vos dossiers vont vous envoyer un code
d'accès qui vont permettre de compléter
votre dossier donc toutes les
informations surtout n'oubliez pas c'est
de motivation copie de carte d'identité
vraiment tout ce qui est demandé parce
que sans ces documents nous on va vous
relancer on va perdre du temps en
sachant que moi étant la charge
développement plus vite j'étais
candidatures mieux c'est parce que je
peux les positionner quand vous arrivez
au début on trouve facilement une
entreprise et plus vous allez perdre du
temps ou passer du temps à vous inscrire
et bien vous aurez mon choix
oui
donc surtout mettez bien les documents
donc une fois que les documents sont
bien saisis bien enregistrés dans le
profil vous participez enfin vous êtes
conviés à une information collective
puis un entretien individuel donc mené
et par les formateurs par moi-même
et en fonction de ça de votre motivation
de votre envie et en fonction aussi de
là vous en êtes dans votre recherche
d'entreprise on vous acceptera la
Faculté des Métiers tout au long de
votre formation le plus simple enfin le
plus simple le plus convaincant je pense
quand on cherche sa voie c'est
effectivement de pouvoir faire des
stages voici de manière aux journées
portes ouvertes nous on en fait
régulièrement alors sur les trois sites
c'est vrai que nous alors je vais parler
pour ma paroisse pour les métiers du
goût généralement nous avons au moins un
formateur de chaque métier et un
apprenti je me trompe pas au moins un et
donc là la première journée portes
ouvertes qui a eu lieu était donc le 28
janvier nous en avons une le 18 mars de
9h à 17h donc là c'est toute la journée
le 14 avril c'est un vendredi c'est le
soir et ensuite le 13 mai et le 24 juin
en demi-journée donc n'hésitez surtout
pas venir vous avez les formateurs qui
sont là vous avez les apprentis et vous
avez toutes les pédagogiques ainsi que
moi-même qui sommes là pour vous
conseiller vous orienter
et vous donner l'envie
n'hésitez surtout pas venir ça vous
permet de pouvoir des fois on hésite
entre un ou deux métiers on sait pas là
vous êtes dans une journée portes
ouvertes vous pouvez rentrer dans nos
ateliers échanger avec les formateurs
peut-être
voir vos par rapport à vos envies nous
on peut vous orienter vous pouvez
vraiment avoir un vrai échange et des
fois on part d'un exemple vers pas la
pâtisserie ou pour la cuisine et puis
aller en fin de compte on hésite entre
deux métiers et avec un échange avec les
formateurs nous on est quand même assez
aguerris là-dessus et on va mieux vous
orienter et on va voilà le fait est que
c'est vraiment
important que vous veniez où j'en ai
portes ouvertes déjà d'une pour vous
pour voir un petit peu et ce qui est
important aussi c'est que si jamais vous
avez un métier qui est déjà arrêté
n'importe lequel ce qui est important
c'est aussi de
on va pas vous cacher dedans retrouver
rapidement un patron parce que ce qu'il
faut penser c'est que
il y aura beaucoup de portes ouvertes
pas que CFA des riz dans d'autres CFA
mais tout sur le même discours trouver
un patron donc le patron va prendre un
ou deux apprentis donc ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué sur la fin plus
on est arrivé vers le mois de juin de
trouver des patrons donc ça c'est
vraiment important même si vous n'êtes
pas encore à la faculté que vous êtes né
vous voulez venir aux jeunes portes
ouvertes rien ne vous empêche de déjà
essayer si vous avez déjà une voix
quelque chose une certitude de trouver
des patrons autour de chez vous qui sont
susceptibles de vous prendre en
apprentissage d'accord ça c'est vraiment
important parce que des fois il y a des
patrons on n'a pas 15000 de chez soi il
vaut mieux trouver un patron qui est pas
trop loin de son domicile pour éviter la
fatigue la pénibilité donc ça c'est
important
avoir des informations sur tel métier
l'inscription quoi que ce soit n'hésitez
pas à contacter donc Madame Rosello qui
est l'assistante de filière voilà c'est
simple pédagogique des boulangers
pâtissiers vous avez ces coordonnées et
Madame aura pour tout ce qui est cuisine
et restauration donc restauration c'est
le service est en salle et là vous aimez
mes coordonnées donc moi je suis la
charge de développement donc comme je
disais tout à l'heure moi mon rôle est
vraiment de développer un partenariat
d'entreprise pour essayer de vous
accompagner au mieux à trouver un
employeur et faire un suivi
de votre formation au sein de votre
entreprise on attend que les formateurs
voilà donc n'hésitez pas à nous
contacter
laissez-nous des messages surtout
laissez-nous des messages parce que vous
êtes plein à nous appeler voilà ne vous
inquiétez pas on essaie d'y répondre au
plus vite selon l'intensité des messages
qu'on a on essaye vraiment d'y répondre
au plus vite donc des fois si vous voyez
qu'on répond pas tout de suite tout de
suite c'est qu'on en a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup donc mais on reviendra
rapidement vers nous
alors
donc
ce qu'on vous propose maintenant c'est
de répondre à vos questions donc
n'hésitez pas dans le chat à mentionner
toutes les questions que vous avez
aujourd'hui et on va dans un premier
temps donner la parole à abidel qui est
donc apprenti en bac pro coiffure
cuisine pardon et qui nous a
non pas excusez-moi
ça fait plaisir de nous rejoindre donc
ce matin puis là tu peux peut-être nous
expliquer quel est ton parcours
qu'est-ce qui t'a amené vers vers le
choix de ce métier là et de
l'apprentissage
moi mon parcours j'ai fait une troisième
générale normale et dès que je suis
sortie de ma troisième je me suis
orienté vers le CFA débrie
faire un bac pro directement
ce que on m'a proposé c'est un peu
c'était vous qui m'avez proposé en plus
donc on m'avait proposé cap BTS BP ouais
et ben bac pro était plus intéressant et
franchement c'est tout j'ai pas grand
chose à donner à dire je suis sorti
direct de ma troisième est-ce que
c'était difficile au premier patron
en tant qu'apprenti un petit peu parce
que il faut s'occuper de l'apprenti quoi
faut surtout en première année il faut
lui donner ses bases tout ça mais
dès qu'on s'en sort ça a eu mal à le
trouver pas plus que ça
justement
faut vraiment bouger selon après faut
faire aussi selon tes envies selon le
restaurant où toi tu as envie d'aller
faut pas aller dans un restaurant parce
que c'est cool il paye bien en gros il y
a une adéquation entre la formation et
le restaurant il y a pas un contrat il
part en restant traditionnel en captrat
traditionnel et travailler dans dans une
collectivité voilà on peut pas
travailler en collectivité en étant en
bas qui c'est pas possible il faut
travailler dans un restaurant privé un
restaurant qui fait émotionnel ou
gastronomie
il faut bien orienter son
patron par rapport à son niveau par
rapport à sa formation niveau d'études
et donc
le reste le restaurant tu
avais cuisine
non ça te plaît
à la maison pour aider maman tout ça je
pense que tout le monde a fait ça quand
il était petit mais non j'avais jamais
eu de personnes dans ma famille qui en
cuisine rien du tout juste comme ça moi
sur un coup peut-être cuisine
franchement et ça m'a pas déçu c'est ça
m'a pas déçu du tout hein ça en apprend
plein de choses dans ce métier on
apprend
des vrais la vraie cuisine quoi ça
change des pâtes de la maison
sympa pour maman ça
et donc le côté le côté
apprendre à bien le fait d'être
ralenti du coup en formation et le fait
d'être en partie en entreprise et comme
disait monsieur tout à l'heure il y a
seulement quelques camarades qui sont
disponibles pour aller faire la fête
alors que toi tu travailles est-ce que
comment ça s'est passé à ce niveau là
pour toi après je pense que ça dépend
des personnes mais
ouais moi ça m'arrive plein de fois de
week-end on me dit viens en sort viens
on fait ça tout ça et moi maintenant je
travaille du coup je peux pas sortir
mais après ça dépend des jours moi
devrait ça me dérange pas plus que ça
c'est une semaine court une semaine au
travail et quand je sais que c'est sur
ma semaine d'école mon week-end je l'ai
tout le temps il y a une organisation
différente à trouver mon week-end quand
c'est sur ma semaine du travail de
l'école mais par contre quand c'est sur
ma semaine du travail je sais que mes
sorties seront limitées que si je prends
pas un jour de congé
j'ai pas vraiment sortir quoi moi même
j'aurais pas la fois sortir avec le
travail
ça te permet de gagner un peu d'argent
que t'aurais pas eu à la fin du mois je
pense que tout le monde est content
c'est son salaire surtout quand tu es
apprenti moi je suis content
alors on a quelques questions après la
classe de 3e pouvons-nous avoir une
rémunération alors je vais repasser la
parole et effectivement à Madame Guillon
qui avait présenté la rémunération des
apprentis donc juste après la classe de
3e en fait c'est ça la question alors
oui effectivement à condition que vous
soyez en contrat d'apprentissage en
alternance et que vous ayez 15 ans
15 ans au moment de la signature du
contrat sinon cette stagiaire mais oui
l'apprentissage de toute façon
généralement ça s'adresse aux jeunes qui
sort de troisième donc troisième cap et
donc si vous avez un contrat oui vous
êtes payé vous êtes rémunéré
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle dès le
départ vous aurez une rémunération qui
sera en proportion de votre âge de votre
formation et ainsi de suite
et à partir de quand doit-on chercher
une entreprise
là maintenant
possible
quel que soit des métiers mais le
premier arrivé premier servi en plus
quand on commence tôt on parle le choix
avec différentes entreprises donc autant
commencer tout de suite bien préparer
vos outils de communication c'est de
motivation préparez votre argumentaire
le mieux alors le mieux avant de
s'orienter dans quel que soit le métier
c'est d'essayer de faire au moins un
petit stage de quelques jours voir si le
métier peut vraiment vous convenir parce
que l'idée qu'on a du métier et la
réalité n'est pas du tout la même
parfois donc chercher dès aujourd'hui à
stage entreprise de toute façon vous
êtes accompagné de votre recherche mais
tant que votre inscription n'est pas
validée non on peut pas vous accompagner
donc faites-le dès à présent n'hésitez
surtout pas moi je dirais même plus
c'est bien d'être accompagné de Papa
Maman par contre à l'entretien c'est
quand même à vous de parler voilà je
dirais tout seul vous pouvez y aller
tout seul c'est encore mieux mais même
si papa maman ou quelqu'un vous
accompagne c'est quand même à vous de
parler au patron c'est pas la personne
qui vous accompagne parce que de toute
façon dans la vie de tous les jours dans
l'entreprise vous serez tout seul avec
le patron de moi tout seul avec d'autres
dans la cuisine ou dans le la formation
que vous ferez en entreprise vous serez
ce sera vous qui serez là et ce sera à
vous d'échanger avec le patron donc
toute façon un patron va faire la
différence parce que c'est pas parce
qu'on va on va aller démarcher un patron
qui va nous prendre forcément lui va
avoir elle va être des marchés par
plusieurs apprentis et c'est lui qui a
façon choix dont vous faut vous vendre
et donc pour ça ben il veut voir votre
engagement votre élocution votre
présentation aussi on y va pas en tenue
on va dire pas correct il faut vraiment
soigner ça sa présentation comme la
libidelle il faut avoir au moins un CV
très simple mais au moins une lettre de
motivation si voilà et pas hésiter à
parler au patron et et échanger avec lui
oui ma présentation aussi il faut pas y
aller
c'est pas conseillé donc vraiment une
tenue propre ça fait voir le sérieux
votre sérieux votre engagement
professionnel d'accord dans n'importe
quel métier que vous voulez faire la
présentation est toujours très
importante et les locutions
on essaie d'avoir une inécution correcte
parce que derrière bah on a on vous
apprendrait quel que soit le métier à
langage professionnel vous allez
apprendre et donc l'attitude est
importante et le la présentation aussi
si je comprends bien faut pas avoir peur
de pousser les portes en fait
présentable faut pas y aller en mode
avec Papa Maman parce que après ça c'est
beaucoup trop enfant et il va pas
vouloir nous prendre
un patron a besoin d'un jeune même si il
sait qu'il est jeune plutôt autonome
mais
quelqu'un d'autonome et responsable
après si vous êtes un peu stressé ou ok
on peut vous accompagner mais ce qui est
important c'est qu'une fois que vous
êtes devant le patron c'est à vous de
parler c'est à vous c'est pas vos
parents parce que c'est ce qui peut
faire la différence d'un patron qui va
vous prendre ou pas d'accord et donc
voilà ce qu'on aura à faire à vous
toutes sur la fin toute sa formation
donc il faut bien le dire à
pour une fois c'est vous qui avez la
parole et vos parents en disent le moins
possible
allez revoir rapidement comme on vous
l'a dit déjà plusieurs fois
tous les apprentis vont rechercher pour
la rentrée dès maintenant des patrons
donc de toute façon le patron n'en
prendra un ou deux donc plus vite vous
avez trouvé vous avez pensé pouvoir août
selon la formation que vous faites
septembre ou septembre vous aurez déjà
un patron ça sera déjà papa maman seront
tranquilles vous vous serez soulagés
vous aurez quelque chose vous pourrez
finir votre année scolaire
tranquillement
on sait que c'est toujours
inquiétude de chaque nouvelle apprenti
de trouver de trouver son entreprise
quelque part le conseil qu'on peut vous
donner maintenant puisque nous sommes du
coup début février c'est tranquillement
de commencer à chercher et puis vous
démarcher et vous finirez on est dans un
métier comme on voulait largement dit où
il y a de l'offre il y a vraiment une
offre d'emploi il y a une recherche donc
des apprentis forcément puisque il faut
savoir que finalement un apprenti sur
deux va rester dans l'entreprise
dans laquelle il a fait son
apprentissage donc c'est vrai que il y a
un enjeu aussi pour l'employeur
l'employant ne fait pas que rendre
service quand il prend un apprenti il a
aussi lui besoin de personnels qualifiés
et qui leur a formé j'ai envie de dire
un petit peu à sa manière de faire ça va
l'intéresser d'avoir un jeune qui l'a
formé qui va rester et qui va rester
avec lui sur l'avenir tout à fait c'est
un pari effectivement voilà sur
un an deux ans voire même plus donc pour
lui c'est vous allez apprendre à
travailler à sa façon vous allez
apprendre à travailler
comment voilà vous devez connaître un
petit peu tous les rois de l'entreprise
donc pour lui à la fin de vous embaucher
c'est intéressant parce que vous savez
déjà travailler à sa façon
donc il n'y a plus d'autres questions
que vous nous avez posé par le chat
n'hésitez pas à le faire à le faire si
vous souhaitez on a encore quelques
quelques minutes ensemble si vous si
vous avez besoin de réponse et puis vous
avez donc les coordonnées effectivement
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter avec moi
alors si vous souhaitez faire un stage
préalable en fait au choix finalement du
métier sachez que au niveau de la
chambre de métier nous vous proposons
des conventions qui nous permettent
pendant les vacances scolaires et
exclusivement par contre pendant les
vacances scolaires de faire jusqu'à 5
jours de stage par vacance dans
n'importe quel dans n'importe quel
métier donc si vous avez besoin de
découvrir un métier c'est important pour
vous de dire à votre employeur que vous
avez la possibilité de lui proposer une
convention avec la chambre des métiers
donc il suffit de nous contacter vous
avez effectivement
le site internet de la chambre du métier
donc moi je m'appelle Marielle m je vous
le rappelle je peux aussi vous aider
donc dans l'établissement de cette
convention de stage
est-ce que on pourrait vous donner un
petit mot de la fin
il est
très bien
qui qui ont éventuellement envie de se
lancer à le faire qu'est-ce que tu
pourrais leur dire pour
terminer cette
honnêtement ce que je pourrais leur dire
c'est de s'accrocher c'est tout parce
qu'il y a des fois c'est compliqué en
tant qu'apprenti mais il faut
s'accrocher pour aller jusqu'au pape
jusqu'au cap jusqu'au diplôme peu
importe c'est qu'un diplôme il faut au
moins aller jusqu'au diplôme et faut pas
le se laisser aller que ça soit au
niveau des notes ou au niveau de à
l'entreprise faut pas se laisser aller
c'est pas un parent qui le dit donc
je pense que effectivement on n'aurait
pas dit
excusez-nous il y a une
dernière question donc on va revenir
vers vous la on a on est en train de
nous la transmettre
ça vient
alors doit-on avoir un bon bulletin de
notes pour intégrer la filière
alors non pas forcément non pas
forcément
ce qu'il faut pour intégrer la filière
c'est surtout la motivation parce que si
vous venez vous
savez pas quoi faire ou les faire
boulangerie ou je sais pas pourquoi pas
ça pas trop nos convaincre la ce qu'il
faut vraiment c'est la motivation alors
les notes on les regarde pas c'est pas
vous mentir regardez appréciations et
c'est pas ce qui va nous dire oui on
prend oui on prend pas c'est pas ça on
va vous prendre en fonction de votre
motivation votre envie vos recherches de
vos retours parce que c'est votre projet
c'est à vous de travailler c'est pas à
nous donc là c'est à vous vraiment de de
vous vendre aussi bien vis-à-vis de
votre employeur que vis-à-vis de nous
mais c'est pas les notes qui que vous
avez qui sont bonnes ou pas qui vont
freiner votre votre inscription ça l'a
Faculté des Métiers pas du tout parce
que c'est vraiment un projet
professionnel donc on va pas on va pas
bloquer une inscription parce que vous
n'avez pas de vous inquiétez pas
rassurez-vous faut vraiment surtout
avoir un projet construit et que c'est
vraiment votre projet pas que ce soit
avec vos parents qui vous disent ce
serait bien que tu fasses c'est un
travail que c'est vous qui allez à
l'école c'est vous qui allez apprendre
un métier tu auras certainement selon le
métier que vous allez faire
l'apprentissage qui aura des exigences
d'horaires de travail de voilà bien il y
a toujours des exigences des comptes des
des choses un peu récurrentes faut que
vous soyez vraiment votre choix à vous
et pas le choix de vos parents donc
après à partir de là
le bulletin oui c'est important et non
les rangs les différents commentaires de
votre bulletin mais c'est surtout c'est
que c'est surtout que
certains d'entre vous peuvent être en
difficulté parce que l'école
c'est c'est un peu compliqué le fait de
rentrer dans une formation des fois on a
des élèves qui étaient en dérive à
l'école et d'un seul coup bah ça va
mieux parce que ils ont ils sont dans
leur branches dans leur métier et d'un
seul coup ils comprennent un petit peu
l'importance des différentes matières de
l'onglet du français des maths alors
qu'avant ils avaient ils avaient
beaucoup de difficultés donc pour nous
c'est pas c'est pas handicap c'est pas
une chose c'est pas voilà il révisoire
c'est vraiment quelque chose pour nous
on estime que ce qui est important c'est
la formation il y a première question je
pense beaucoup à vous deux quelle est la
différence entre le Cap et le patron
alors les deux alors de choses qui sont
on va prendre plus ou moins la même
chose au départ c'est-à-dire que un cap
vous aurez de l'enseignement général
comme le bac pro selon votre âge aussi
c'est à dire que si en fin de première
vous êtes majeur on peut vous donner sur
le bac pro la possibilité de passer
aussi le cap c'est à dire qu'en trois
ans vous si vous êtes majeur je dis bien
enfin de première vous allez faire deux
secondes première et si vous êtes majeur
on vous donne la possibilité de passer
le cap et l'année suivante vous passerez
le pack donc ça vous donne la
possibilité de passer
deux diplômes en trois ans le cap à la
finalité vous n'aurez que cap or c'est
un diplôme qui est inférieur au bac pro
mais pour certains des fois
ils veulent ils veulent faire un cap
sans faire un bac voilà après après le B
le cap on peut partir sur un brevet
professionnel qui est encore deux ans
mais qui est plus technique on va dire
on ne prend plus de temps on va plus
loin qui le BP le bac pro ont la même au
même niveau mais on est plus compétent
avec un BP que un bac pro parce que bon
on a déjà 4 ans de cuisine derrière donc
on est beaucoup plus compétent c'est un
peu plus exigeant voilà après l'un et
l'autre ça dépend vraiment de votre
niveau à l'école si par exemple on est
on avait vraiment des grosses grosses
difficultés dans les matières générales
on va plus orienter vers un cap vous
allez prendre vraiment le temps de
monter de d'assimiler un petit peu tout
ce que vous devez apprendre et si vous
avez un niveau à peu près correct on va
plus vous orienter vers un bac pro voilà
ça dépend après votre niveau scolaire de
vos envies de beaucoup de choses ça on
utilise ça donc avec Madame Dubillon et
à l'entretien et nous on discute avec
vous et ça va orienter votre formation
il y a une dernière question je pense
que ça va être la dernière là du coup
compte tenu de l'horaire
quels sont les horaires de cours par
semaine ça va dépendre ça va dépendre un
petit peu de la formation
par exemple si vous allez faire un titre
qualifiant à titre pro ou un PSR
voilà ça va être trois jours deux jours
ou
deux jours chaque semaine
en général sur le cap c'est pareil sur
le sur le bac pro c'est pareil
en fonction des formations soit c'est
une semaine une semaine des bacs c'est
ça
après les bacs les BP en boulangerie les
BTM c'est 4 jours après généralement
quatre jours de cours et une semaine en
entre et la semaine suivante pardon en
entreprise généralement fait la plupart
des formations que nous avons c'est deux
jours CFA rejoint entreprise quand ce
sont des alors quand les journées sont
des journées où se sont que des matières
dites générales les heures de cours sont
de 8h30 à 16h30 quand il y a atelier en
fonction des métiers vous commencez
entre 7H 7h30 voir 8 heures pour la
cuisine non
et bah plutôt vous commencez plutôt
utiliser donc vous finissez vos cours et
15h30 on a deux horaires si vous
commencez à 7h30 à 15h30 ça peut arriver
selon la formation que vous faites
commencez à 12h30 et finir à 19h30 et
après selon le diplôme on peut commencer
même à 15h et finir à
21h mais là on est plus sur les diplômes
des terminales ou des ou des brevets
professionnels
faut faire 35 heures temps de présence
entreprise troncent ces femmes
les employeurs que nous proposons
on arrive sur la fin de cette
présentation j'espère qu'elle vous a
permis de mieux comprendre les métiers
donc du coup que vous pouvez apprendre
par l'apprentissage
n'hésitez surtout pas si vous souhaitez
des informations complémentaires à
joindre le CFA de votre choix et
notamment donc le CFA de la faculté des
métiers que qui vous a fait cette
présentation aujourd'hui on vous
remercie beaucoup et puis à très bientôt
peut-être au revoir au revoir